The more I read about the Gulag System in,
in the USSR and what happened in China,
what happened in Nazi Germany,
the more it became evident to me that
these weren't top down systems imposed by
tyrants on an unwilling
innocent population,
but decisions on the part of entire
cultures to go down a certain road.
Often the leaders were following,
which I would say it was
particularly the case with Hitler,
which isn't to deny him
his criminal culpability,
but Hitler was unbelievably good at
letting the crowd tell him what to say.
You know,
he was a,
he was a mirror for the crowd
and he was a good orator,
but he paid attention to the crowd.
And so when he said something
that made everyone cheer,
you know,
they're dark hearts would come out in
the mob and cheer about something he said
that was say dramatic or vengeful.
Well then he'd say more of that and the
things that he said that were peaceful,
that produced no emotional
reaction from the crowd.
He just said less of.
And so the crowd taught him over time
exactly what to sell them and that that
can be good in some sense.
If a leader does that carefully,
that that means he's integrating what
the crowd wants with his style of
leadership.
But it can be terrible if the mob is the
crowd and the mob is outraged and out
for blood,
and that's what happened in Nazi Germany.
And so you can't blame it on Hitler.
That's just not reasonable.
It's distributed through
the entire population and
it's at the individual level
of analysis that's most significant.